ich habe einen pokal
löw meine lieben freuen und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commons heute am dienstag
wo ich euch ja immer einen command
vorstelle der ihnen ein bisschen
umfangreicher ist oder den ich nicht in
die andere folge mit rein nehmen möchte
oder so weiter und so fort heute ist es
wieder ein command von barrett engineer
weil er in letzter zeit einfach richtig
neiße commands raushaut es tut mir leid
dass ich da immer so meine 678 quellen
habe wo ich die commands hernehme und
ich habe auch gesehen dass viele von
euch schon commands geschrieben haben um
ihren die kommentare geschrieben am hey
ich hab auch ein command gemacht blabla
schau dir den normalen werde ich in dem
nächsten mal machen
allerdings bin ich derzeit komplett ein
vorprodukt sofort zu ich bin roussel
übrigens neuerdings bin am videos planen
vor produzieren weil ich bin düsseldorf
zwei tage bin wegen webvideo preis dann
bin ich sieben tage new york zwei tage
berlin so ein bisschen unterwegs und
muss deswegen videos ford produzieren
deswegen fangen wir auch eigentlich
schon direkt mit dem komma wir geben
direkt ein / gfp command unterstrichen
block um das essensgeld notwendigste für
diese commands folge zu erhalten und
zwar einen command block sondern haben
uns auch direkt schon hier einen hebel
und platzieren das ganze hier sieht ganz
schön nah an das gefällt nicht so will
man hier nicht so schön und was mache
ich schon wieder für ein schelm
bestellten hier zwischen die blumen soll
dann packen wir ihn hier hin
hier finden wir zehn kommen und das ist
ein sehr sehr langer command und zwar
wenn ich jetzt hier mal drauf drücke ich
muss euch wirklich sagen dieser command
wurde von der engine ihr konnte nicht
weiter gemacht werden weil er das limit
erreicht hat also er wollte irgendwie
noch mehr verfügbare mops hinzufügen und
so allerdings geht es nicht weil er halt
dieses komplette zeichen limit für
command erreicht hat jedenfalls haben
wir das hier jetzt und ihr seht schon
command poke boards beider räte jenny
und zwei ist ein pokémon kommt hier
klicken auf get it right click wissen
vor info dann klicken wir drauf und wir
sehen schon drop on ground redstone das
debattenende und ingo kräfte ball soll
redstone das und eisenerz habe ich mir
schon geholt und jetzt hole ich mir hier
noch die knöpfe und zwar schmeiße ich
jetzt redstone platz dustin eisenwaren
und einen knopf und dann seht ihr schon
ich habe einen pokal den kann ich jetzt
ganz simple einsammeln allerdings was ja
auch wissen müsst wenn ich
beispielsweise drei brettern
hinschmeißen drei eisen machen und drei
knöpfe
bekomme ich trotzdem noch einen pokal
raus das heißt es könnten zum beispiel
nicht in stack hier von stec redstone
tasten schmeißen spec eisenwaren und sp
knöpfe dann bekommt ihr nicht ins bett
poker bälle sondern ihr bekommt dann
trotzdem noch einen pokal
allerdings habe ich jetzt hier von zwei
stücke heißen auch hier schön im
inventar pokal eigentlich ist es in
minecraft skull das sieht man darunter
eingeblendet habe ich ja diese texte
aktiviert womit viele fragen wie ich das
gemacht habe ich ehrlich gesagt keine
ahnung hat wie ich das gemacht habe ich
bekomme oft kennt wichtig auch ganz
simpel was ich jetzt hier mitmachen kann
ist ich kann mich neben einem mob
stellen wie beispielsweise schweine
werden supported hasen bin ich mir nicht
sicher können wir gleich testen die
chicken werden
supported im hühner werden appell der
hühner werden supported für werden
supported creeper und der ganze antrag
auch die meisten kommen most common mops
werten hat allerdings ja ich schmeiße
jetzt hier auf jeden fall erstmal eine
puppe mal drauf und jetzt haben wir eine
13 chance dass das ganze klappt wir
sehen schon hier rechts gerade
eingeblendet okay zwei von drei
und jetzt schauen wir mal ob das drei
von drei klappt und nein es hat nicht
geklappt das pokémon oder bzw das
schwein ist wieder entwischt und wir
haben jetzt hier wieder unseren poker
ball zurück gerät engineered im video
nichts gesagt ob es so wie bei pokemon
ist das heißt wenn ich das schaf das
schwein hier irgendwie vorher viermal
schlag ob es dann eine höhere chance hat
dass ich das irgendwie kriegen kann
das ist ja bei pokemon sondern alle die
das irgendwie mal gespielt haben oder
immer noch spielen wenn ich das pokémon
vorher so ein bisschen schwächer dann
ist es immer von kappa kpc ap weniger
was es hat leichter das pokémon zu
bekommen ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich
ist es jetzt zu fall und jo wood pick es
ist möglich also ich weiß ich hab es
möglich ist aber als ao hallo chicken es
hat auf jeden fall gerade geklappt aber
ich denke nicht dass es damit irgendwie
zusammenhängt und hätte es auch ein
video gesagt das war zufall
und jetzt habe ich hier in court pick
und das kann jetzt beispielsweise hier
wieder hinsetzen jetzt habe ich ein
gespann gefangen schwein oder sie schon
kurt pick heißt es jetzt einfach anders
kann jetzt hinsetzen allerdings
haben die teile keine besondere
eigenschaft jetzt ich kann damit quasi
nur mops mitnehmen und mustern quasi
nicht wenn ich irgendwie eine herde von
kühen oder von von von hier von hühnern
mitnehmen möchte muss ich dann nicht
alle komisch mitnehmen mit irgendwelchen
samen und durch die pampa laufen sondern
kann einfach auf irgendwie 34 stück
davon ich mal wenn die chance 1 zu 3 ist
und ich will unbedingt zwei stück haben
brauche ich halt höchstens expo quelle
um zwei mitzunehmen und kann die dann
einfach so mitnehmen ich weiß ich bin
gut in mathe allerdings hole ich mir
jetzt hier noch einen eisen block und
einen redstone block und zwar wird das
ganze nicht beschrieben allerdings hat
erst in seinem video gezeigte ersten
pokal habe ich hier ganz normal im pokal
und wenn ich jetzt den pokal
hinschmeißen und einen eisen blog und
eine red storm block dann seht ihr schon
bekomme ich das was passiert hier gerade
neu was ich habe gerade einen poker
ballin redstone block und reisen login
geschmissen und ich bekomme einen eisen
blog ist es ist ernst hat euch das an
das einzige was kommt ist catching noch
und alles verwandelt sich zu einem
gefangenen was ist das das ist gerade
ein komischer fehler okay das fakt mich
grad so ein bisschen ab weil das
eigentlich so eine geile funktion ist
nicht unbedingt zeigen wollte weil ich
erklärte jetzt einfach mal
oder war es die falsche reihenfolge der
ich das geschmissen aber das kann
endlich sein weil ich den pokal auf
meiner falschen reihenfolge schmeiße
also ich habe hier ein poker ball kann
ihn dahin setzen kanadas rausschmeißen
das rausschmeißen das klappt nicht und
wenn ich einen pokal hinschmeißen und
dann das und das klappt auch nicht also
ich weiß nicht genau was das ganze jetzt
hier soll aber dafür habe ich ja immer
noch einen mund und einem minecraft
account kann ich das ganze hier einfach
zeigen ich weiß nicht ob es an mir liegt
oder an an dem command oder an ob es bei
euch auch nicht klappt oder weiß ich
nicht aber er hat in seinem video
gezeigt dass wenn ich ein poker ball hin
schmal zu sagen damals im pokal einen
eisen block und einen redstone blog das
ist nicht wahr
jetzt klappt das hier auf eimer oder
wart ja meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen hier ist die falle nachdem
ich einen ganz normalen kopfing
geschmissen haben und keinen pokal
danach hat es geklappt irgendwie komisch
der fall und zwar kann ich euch schon
genau zeigen was die macht und zwar das
fast es sehr kritisch hatten die falle
blockiert nämlich alle mops im umkreis
von zwei blöcken das heißt wenn ich hier
mops einsätze passiert erstmal nix
allerdings schon sofort wenn ein mob
auch nur in die nähe von dieser falle
läuft von diesem poker ball dann seht
ihr schon dass dem dass der mob einfach
angezogen wird und ich quasi die ganzen
mops hier dran habe das ist ein
zusatzeffekt neben dem effekt dass wir
noch poker bälle haben und so weiter und
so fort mégane eis also ich könnte jetzt
hier rein theoretisch mal diese ganzen
mops hin packen und die würden dort so
lange bleiben bis ich quasi dieses
teilen damit zerstören würde das heißt
ich würde jetzt mal eben durchlaufen
wird jetzt mal dieses ding rein damit
den ganzen störender manager treasuries
okay das funktioniert kommt irgendwie
nicht also ich könnte jetzt rein
theoretisch die falle die da ist in der
mitte einfach zerstören dann würden die
alle wieder losgelassen werden
allerdings jetzt haben wir gerade erst
mal eine kleine rammel farben sage ich
mal so in etwa und das ist quasi das
zweite messe neben dem pokal hinzugefügt
wird das ist die falle einfach im kopf
anscheinend keinen pokal im video zeigt
den pokal allerdings ist dann
wahrscheinlich im kopf als ein blog und
redstone blog hinschmeißen aber kommt
man an dem ort eine falle und da werden
die ganzen mops angezogen wenn ich dann
allerdings die falle gleich wieder
zerstören würde was ich nicht machen
kann weil die irgendwie von den ganzen
kühnen belagert ist dann würde ich nur
den pokal und eisenberg zurückbekommen
der redstone blog würde einfach so
verschwinden quasi so als tribut dafür
oder als tribut ich weiß gar nicht genau
auf jeden fall so als als item was dann
so verschwindet dafür dass nichts kaputt
gemacht habe sage ich mal ja freunde das
war jetzt hier auch schon für den
dienstag der einzelne command wurde
jetzt doch recht umfangreich ich bin bei
mir grad in der tasche noch zehn minuten
werde ich jetzt natürlich irgendwie
runter kürzt wieder im schnitt ich hoffe
euch das video gefallen es getan hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen und dann sehen wir uns in einem
anderen video wieder wenn ihr das video
gerade seht doch bin ich noch in
deutschland also das ist ja ein video
ist auch komplett egal ist